aux antilles les décisions de jacques
landes en faveur des langues régionales
à l'école était attendu dans ces
départements
le français coexiste avec le créole en
attente d'une pleine reconnaissance ce
dernier est déjà enseigné à mayotte en
revanche territoires français de l'océan
indien des langues parlées comme le
shimaoré ne sont pas autorisés en classe
dans cette île majoritairement non
francophones le suma aurait demeure la
langue locale la plus utilisée au
quotidien
mais désormais certains collèges incite
les élèves à utiliser le français au
sein de leur établissement
le français étant la langue de
l'intégration et de la réussite sociale
j'te dispensable que la règle du jeu
soit a soit nettement défini c'est à
dire en classe pour des raisons
d'efficacité ne serait ce que parce que
face à ce que tout le monde se connaît
comprennent on parle français puis en
plus c'est la langue de leur avenir
c'est là dedans qui vont passer des
sciences sociales qui ont passé des
examens en classe est obligé qu'on parle
français mais dehors on a le droit de
parler man ray avec ses copines
conscients que leur avenir professionnel
en dépend pendant les cours les élèves
pratiquent donc avec assiduité le
français mais l'apprentissage de cette
langue est difficile et pendant les
récréations
les règlements sont oublié le temps où
de cet intermède